sometimes i feel like i've already seen
everything that's gonna happen
and it's a nightmare
this is a movie that's based upon a
young man who makes a really important
decision to
join the army during the iraq war the
shock that he experiences in
iraq is something that he can't shake
for the rest of the film
he comes back with undiagnosed ptsd it's
an invisible infliction
people see someone with ptsd and go oh
that guy's fine he came home and he
wasn't injured
i have this noise in my head it'll stop
one day it'll just go quiet
i came home from iraq in 2003 my family
friends they had no idea really what was
going on internally with me
when you're coming out of a combat zone
it is very jarring to return to the
civilian world you don't want to talk
about it sometimes you don't want to go
through it again
the medical system was unprepared to
help charity with these issues
how's your pain level nine out of ten
have you ever heard of oxycontin
they misprescribe opioids and that turns
into a bad addiction for him and that
ends up turning into a life of crime get
on the ground now
living with ptsd took me to some pretty
dark places
i was addicted to drugs and alcohol and
i spent a year of my life in prison
every week there was a younger version
of me walking through those doors
we have lost family members we have
others who are struggling with their
sobriety
there's a scale to this that is
terrifying
there's about 3.3 million of us that
served in iraq and afghanistan and there
are still
far too many that do fall through the
cravings sometimes they give up hope
you know that's why it's so important to
tell these stories a movie like cherry
helps all of us to understand that it's
okay to reach out for help
and we as a country can begin this
healing process together
you're in for me i feel the same way
cherry represents the possibility
of a bright future
i believe this film is going to help
people and get the struggle
out to the masses they show the grid of
not just combat but coming back
on the other side there are so many
therapies that are out there
it's going to be different for all of us
we have to understand that
but hope is mandatory we have to do
everything we can to make sure that we
leave no one behind
we owe it to the ones that did not come
back to live
a happy and healthy life the service men
and women here today really are
unparalleled
and we're indebted to them in every way
sometimes i feel like i've already seen
everything that's gonna happen
but for the first time it didn't scare
me
[Music]
you